well how about we talk about some sports
oh sure sport sure me someone I saw a
few people in chat booing me because
they like the white socks yeah you know
I'm a Cubs fan what can I say whatever
I've been I went to a bunch of Cubs game
as a kid I listened to Harry Caray I
sang with that dude I was fun I watched
him when I was in Sweden actually at the
time when they won the World Series I
was like 4:00 in the morning
right I was there started screaming in
the house I was like oh wait it's 4:00
in the morning I was outside of Wrigley
Field cool
and cops were lined up like there's
gonna be a riot uh-huh and then after
they won like most people just walked
calmly home in huge crowds oh yeah it
was great
standing outside of an empty stadium and
they won and it's a crazy moment for the
Cubs man what an awesome game that was
that was such a good series why don't we
talk about this guy here yeah sorry what
are we talking about Mike Gundy
apologizes for Ohain hold on let me
press my ears for a Tim rant yes I think
I think I think did you get it out
already see what I was telling you hear
it yeah take a story at Oklahoma State
Cowboys coach Mike Gundy Gundy
apologized Tuesday for the pain and
discomfort he caused his players and
others because of a t-shirt he was
photographed wearing and vowed positive
changes for his football program while
fishing what pain was caused to anyone
because he was wearing a t-shirt yeah it
said all right for a news network
seriously though because it's doing
Network that Trump likes but they're far
right not even the apology came one day
after running back chubba Hubbard took
to social media to call out Gundy for
wearing a t-shirt from Oh a n1 American
News a photo showing Gundy wearing the
t-shirt appeared on social media and the
day that followed Gundy and Hubbard
appeared in a video message together
that drew widespread criticism then
Hubbard posted twice more about needing
to hold Gandhi accountable for pushing
for change in the Tuesday afternoon
video Gundy said he met with his players
who told him why the shirt affected them
one American news is a far-right news
network that is often cited by President
Donald Trump this far-right mean to
these people you think you can call it a
Trump loyalist Network sure are they
like are they are they laissez-faire
capitalists arguing for the dissolution
of the regulatory state I don't think so
or they are traditional ists saying that
women should get back in the control no
Trump support yes
doesn't mean anything far right there's
a funny thing about the far left is
they're literally Marxist oh yeah like
they're they're actually advocating for
a far left economy and culture oh yeah
the far right isn't even far right no
anyway
all right the network which is a
fraction of the audience of Fox News I
don't see why that's relevant has tried
to position itself as a place for a pro
Trump audience that believes other
conservative news outlets have become
too mainstream in their reporting it
recently criticized the black lives
matter movement at a great meeting with
our team today our players express their
feelings as individuals and as team
members they helped me see through their
eyes how the t-shirt affected their
hearts once I learned how that Network
felt about black lives matter I was
disgusted and who was completely
unacceptable to me and it was at that
moment that my spine fell clean out of
my shorts and I seem to have misplaced
it now he didn't he was out at the time
and then a fish jumped right up and
grabbed it and then it swam away and I'm
like oh geez were my gonna do so you
know now it's really not my fault that I
have to apologize I mean my spine was
stolen by a fish
you know what it feels like you know the
horseshoe where it comes they're coming
back to meet each other so it feels like
the far left has gone so far it's like
you know when you go off-screen and you
appear on the other side of the screen
that's what it feels like
I don't like boo now there are now they
are the far right and they're looking
around they're like oh man
well this is where we are now it's the
horseshoe they're there they touched
yeah that you know it's like someone
tweeted that's like it's the teardrop
theory I gotta 14 demands right but I
never seen more racist stuff than I
haven't apologized except I want to
apologize to all members of our team
former players and their families for
the pain and discomfort that has been
caused over the last two days because he
wore a t-shirt well to go fishing yes
seriously
bromine
somebody was like you oh yeah you got
your shirt wet you like oh we spelled
you be here here's a shirt it's like oh
great he puts it on yeah and also I you
know when you fish you don't wear your
good shirt seriously like what come on
well I mean I I used to be a fisherman
you know so like I know the deal you get
you get blood you know wear a tuxedo to
go fishing yeah it's not a you know
clean I don't know sport or hunting
hunting is it clean right exactly
check is that silly you want to know the
world you're helping create mr. Gundy
Saints quarterback Drew Brees apologizes
again against de Meyer what did you do
in the first place he said I will never
agree what I think he said I will never
agree with someone who would see Niels
for the flavor yeah someone who
disrespects the place respects the fly
right cuz my grandfather fought for it
yeah that was his house it that's it
that's it I will never agree with
someone who disrespects the flag so
you're not allowed to you're not allowed
to disagree with someone yep I will
never agree with you no no no they're
allowed to disagree with you and you got
to bend the knee right that's all he
said was I won't ever agree with
somebody that's it right yeah Wow yes
that's sad and no no but did you know
apologize oh yes yes no I think he did
it like four times to be honest his wife
did it too and everything the more you
apologize bru drew drew brew whatever
your name is it's like dude the more you
apologize the more they're gonna want
you to apologize there is an ancient
cycle oh wait we could probably get
another one out of them Oh totally yeah
struggle session bro yeah keep smacking
him around there's a there's an ancient
I believe it's a Greek proverb proverb a
society grows great when people plant
trees in whose shade they know they will
never sit you know this is the opposite
of that yeah drew brees and Mike Gandhi
are like oh sorry son I gotta chop the
tree down because they're mad at me they
say the tree is racist so it's a white
oak welcome my friends to the world that
people like Mike Gundy hath wrought SDG
nd worker fired over all
racist gesture says he was cracking his
knuckles let me take you to a world and
tell you a grand story once upon a time
there was a man a Mexican man who is out
for working on his dream job he said
finally getting a job with The Electric
Company
he was driving his truck on the way to
work one day when he stopped at a light
okay outside of his car he reached his
hand and stretched and decided to crack
his knuckles and in the midst of
cracking his knuckles a zealous fanatic
noticed well that his hands had made a
particular motion oh oh no there I say
this man was accused of making a white
supremacist hand gesture oh my gosh and
he got fired for it I'm so sick of that
and he got fired for okay symbol uh-huh
the perfect signal
I just here's a photo I just took the
the course for scuba diving you know you
got to take a course oh no you can't use
anymore
oh is that is that part of it yeah when
you're when you need to show that
everything's okay
that's the symbol you can't do it nope
you can clear this I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna do it do it you when I when I do
it you know hey okay you have to in the
test that's what you you get there like
they test you or like all right you know
the symbol for okay and you know it'll
happen right now everything it was okay
you know it'll happen if you make the
okay symbol right now on that camera
what though clip it don't clip it and
they'll say white supremacists show I'm
not kidding I'm serious yeah and then
it'll appear on a bunch of far-left
sites and then you'll get people who
work for NBC News sending it to Google
saying they're making white supremacy
hand gestures people are so stupid yeah
yeah I'm starting to feel you know Tim
yeah I gotta I gotta push you up push it
away look at this image get away well
the picture up okay you see what he's
doing here that's not even his index
finger you can see the shadow between
his fingers it's clearly his Randall
finger ring finger he's cracking his
knuckles he's a Mexican dude who he he
said he didn't even know what this was
he said one of my supervisors said that
I was being accused of doing a white
supremacist gesture that was baffling I
don't know how long it's gonna take me
to get over this but to lose your dream
job for playing with your fingers is a
hard pill to swallow
oh man yeah it's ridiculous
look at the chat everybody no as far as
I'm concerned is just telling us
everything's everything's okay yeah I
tweeted once I love your chat chat you
guys you guys are awesome
yes which we write this one yeah yeah
yeah when this whole thing started I
tweeted the okay symbol yeah and then
responded to it saying I just want
everyone to realize things are gonna be
a-ok yeah and a bunch of leftist started
go like screeching and like and they
were like Tim poles mask is slipped he's
done the emoji I'm like oh oh no I used
an apple emoji on my Twitter account
what does that mean
wait you better cancel the emoji bro
I once made a surprise that's still a
thing there was it wasn't there was an
article that came out that said it was
from the Guardian I think that mixed
mixed-race people have something called
something akin to hybrid vigor where
it's like there's less likelihood of
genetic defect among people that are
further apart in genetics okay make
sense I made a video about it jokingly
talking about mixed-race supremacy and
they start but what do you think the
left said what do you think they called
me when I made that a white supremacist
yes this is why I can't stand these
people because I can't even make a joke
about myself yeah talking about a
scientific article where it's literally
talking about why homogenized racism is
less like is more likely to have genetic
defect mm-hmm you can't even say that
because no matter what you do politics
flows in one direction yeah it's like
make them make the okay hand gesture
white supremacists you have a middle
finger white supremacists do do that do
the the dog wolf pack from NWO do do
annual party do anything other than what
we say yeah white supremacist we're an
Oso understand now yes you don't wear a
white OH don't wear an Owen shirt
silence silence man which is why what
are you gonna do yeah I linked his
violence to each is violent
you overcook the chicken jim-jim believe
it or not okay hold on let's bring his
downs by this down silence is violence
yes yes
stretches violence so far so good yeah
violence physical violence not violent
no is violence it is oh it is no I'm
sorry self-defense oh yes okay and
violence against property not violence
at all protests protests processing
grief yes yeah now now hold on violence
against the vulnerable of the wrong race
hmm restorative justice right yeah so
when they so when they attacked uh
that's a joke I made on Twitter when the
rioters came in trashed a bodega
owned by a minority couple in Britain
the Bronx okay I'm like we have to
understand these are property owners
this is restored I'm you think I'm
joking do you think they actually owned
it or were they renting the space oh yes
renting it right so they probably
weren't even property owners so you have
poor people in places like Ferguson and
when the rioters come from outside of
Ferguson in Missouri I'll smash up the
local businesses mm-hmm the woke lefties
in their ivory tower go well you don't
understand it's restorative justice
they're fighting back against their
oppressors I'm like we're talking about
they torched the local community yeah
it's there's no one oppressing it's like
there's a hair salon dude it was owned
by the lady who lives two blocks away
right neighborhood yeah seriously well
I'll tell you what man take a look this
guy here's the crazy thing to this out
NBC 7 spoke to the man who originally
posted the picture on Twitter he has
since deleted his account huh and said
he may have gotten spun up about the
interaction and misinterpreted he says
he never intended for Cafferty to lose
his job how much one about that dude
white yeah I'm sorry man
yeah I would have had a lot of money in
this I got some white dude yeah I'm
gonna go full US job SJW right now do it
oh man here's have you seen that meme
have you have you seen the meme get him
Tim get him yes have you seen the meme
where it's a woman being force-fed milk
oh yeah yeah and then there's the other
meme where the guys looking over his
shoulder they're combined and it's all
white people yeah
the milk is white guilt the milk is
white guilt finally enough yes
and then it's white people pouring white
guilt into white people's mouths while a
white person looked at the guy shocked
while the white person looks over his
shoulder at the white guilt like it's
good and I gotta say men
it's funny how they rag on my people all
day and they prove their own point the
most privileged narcissistic egotistical
so it's like guilty conscience man maybe
maybe you know there was a someone
brought this up you know what reset the
clock is the hashtag what is it it's a
meme referencing when a male feminist
turns out to be a rapist because it
happened so often so whenever it happens
like reset the clock like days since you
know yeah but I've heard your
explanation of this and it makes total
sense yeah exactly that's what's gonna
bring up when or just why feminists are
feminists no no the the male feminist
turns into a rapist it's because they're
they're only being a male feminist to
get late to get yeah yeah it's not about
what feminists the other the other point
is that if you're a feminist and you're
surrounded by these kind of dudes and
then you're going all men are awful ya
know fighting well yeah you're sued
right like maybe you go hang out with
some regular people problem for like I
don't know playing a game a corn hole in
the backyard and having a you know piece
of chicken or whatever but you choose to
hang out the [ __ ] hat-wearing weirdos
who are constantly saying like know that
I'm your friend do it you owe me sit and
they're like oh man am i right and who
you're right
and that's what they're surrounded by
yeah so if you're one of these whoa you
know white upper-class people surrounded
by a bunch of snooty elitist narcissists
and then you're like man it sure is
funny all these white people are snooty
elitist narcissists yeah and they go on
a crusade about it
not realizing it's them it's you it's
you you're not a problem yeah yeah
you're the problem and they don't get it
so anyway I'll tell you what there are
days when I feel all hope is lost when I
look to the news and what do I see they
banned books they banned art they banned
art it's okay to him I'm here for you
but then I see a bunch of like slightly
overweight South Philly dudes with
baseball bats oh yeah feeling like you
want to come in my neighborhood smash up
my statues get out of here you crazy bum
and I'm like wow regular people are
snapping off so like so like a young
Bernie Sanders well young Bernie Sanders
probably sounded a bit
like this I'm being arrested don't help
me care for everybody yeah I mean look
respect for Bernie for protesting and
civil rights he got arrested for that's
cool yeah that's cool like the photo of
him using he's a good but now he's an
old dude and he doesn't understand
economics and and he's got no spine
either mm-hmm
you know what we need money we need
spines yes we need we need a shipment
perhaps we can call for an import
somewhere just a raw shipment of spines
to hand out to people from China not
from China yeah but maybe we they'd give
us breakable spines sure there's there's
an uptick in 3d printing maybe we can
just you know no we don't need the
spines but we're we're pretty good I
think we're good I mean yeah for for
you're not liberal no I'm not but for us
who have been always fairly liberal
people yeah of liberals we probably have
like the best spines Frank everyone a
good bit we have the best the best human
atom best spines everybody agrees mm-hmm
everybody not like right fallout China
no reason I've been fishing before and I
didn't lose my spine I did not fall out
i I just I wonder what it is that makes
a bunch of spineless people and I don't
care if you're a liberal if you're
conservative if you're progressive is
your if your far right whatever how do
you end up with people who are just so
pathetic and weak that they won't stand
up for themselves what's that saying if
you don't stand for anything you'll fall
you feel don't stand for something
you'll fall for anything yeah yeah yeah
what was that we have Public Enemy or is
that a famous quote that's basically
what we've been saying about people not
having purpose it's the same thing
exactly yeah they don't have a purpose
to stand for so they just believe
whatever garbage is shoveled on their
throat right right man yeah used to be
even just being American like that was
what people could stand like man well
I'm a mayor cam you know living the
American dream yeah that's gone dude as
far as this craziness that I'm seeing
every day but I don't I don't believe
that for one I don't believe it I think
people are gonna realize our certain
people are gonna realize that most
Americans are like no no no we're proud
of America
we're proud of where we live we
proud of this land and we are living the
American dream
that's all races to I'm not that's
that's not there's no don't try to make
it a racial thing because it's not it's
it's simple live in in America they they
they are teaching kids to hate this
country
yep yeah this really thing is you know I
was talking to a friend a friend of mine
about this about you know what it means
to live in this country and what this
country accomplished compared to other
countries
and I'm like you know I think a lot of
these woke white lefties don't
understand what it really means that
this country has civil rights and there
are a lot of European countries that
also have civil rights but as they start
to bring back the racialization of law
I'm like you realize there are very very
few countries that accept cohabitation
like we had loving day reason that's why
I bring it up right loving day is the
anniversary of when the Supreme Court
ruled interracial cohabitation and
marriage was acceptable and I mean
literally like you could have a roommate
who is not your race so messed up yeah
that's crazy right they dude
well there are still many countries
where it's still considered extremely
taboo like most countries actually yeah
and here the most people probably don't
even know that yeah they don't still
exist in an ivory tower
yes that's what America what's what's
that saying who's that the gun rights
thing he said just call the police
is it as a tower so so ivory that you'll
go blind from looking at it look it up
look it up it's a really really good
quote this dude basically calls out
liberals who are like you know if you're
in danger you don't need to defend
yourself called the police and he said
he said just call the police is a tower
so ivory that it'll blind it you know
yeah you plead to find it no a tower so
ivory or something I'm sure they're
pulling it up I'm sure they'll find it
before me they usually do it's an
awesome quote but it reminds me of these
people who grow up in the suburbs they
have it's amazing they go to these
colleges and they're told by their
professors
here's which have to do to be a good
person and then I end up with these
people coming to me and they're like I'm
from Naperville my parents paid my
college let me teach you about what
racism really is and I'm like let me
stop you right there buddy I'm from the
city yeah
the Southside let me tell you about
racism and they say you're a bigot how
dare you you wouldn't try to tell you me
have white privilege no I can't find it
anywhere Gene Wilder what was it from
Gene Wilder no no no right that's just
one of my favorite memes take somebody
meanwhile there's amazing I don't know
if somebody found it yes tell me more
tell me more about how oh yeah yes I
know that Mean Gene well there's the
boss one of the great oh gee comedians
was in Blazing Saddles which shot that
I'm shocked it has been SJW out to
oblivion I can't wait to see it don't
you dare do it don't do it don't give
them ideas at him no man I found it it's
too late someone's gonna see it
eventually it's located it
I believe it's it's from Kaleb how okay
I just googled it I'm not sure he said
banning weapons is the most white
privilige idea ever
rich liberal scoffing at the idea that a
person might need to defend their own
life is a tower so ivory you can't look
at it and direct sunlight it's the
personal safety equivalent of just have
the maid do it man I think that's his
quote Wow but I bring it up it's not a
direct it doesn't directly correlate
with what I was saying but it does in
the sense that these these rich white
suburbanite progressives are the epitome
of what they claim to be fighting
against it's like how do you how do you
fight that when there's people like
could you imagine the vampire hunters
show up to the town hall like we're here
to fight the vampires and then they have
fangs and they're covered in blood in
your light it's literally you and
they'll shop vampire and then they start
stabbing you they kill you real quick
yep
that's what it is yeah it's like it's
them dude they're the zombies they're
not zombie hunters men thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you